d'ailleurs c'est l'histoire du Sénat
très franchement ce niveau de tension
c'est d'autant plus inédit que la gauche
avait souhaité que l'article 7 ne soit
pas voté avant la mobilisation des 7
mars et franchement on était très
patient pendant 5 jours 5 nuits on a
écouté patiemment et en réalité le
contrat n'a pas été si j'ose dire honoré
puisque il fallait non seulement aller
le 7 mars pour voter le 7 mais dès
qu'elle est le plus possible et on s'est
aperçu que en réalité il voulait rien
voter du tout donc le Sénat a adopté
l'article 7 est-ce que vous le dites
vous offrez une bouffée d'oxygène à
Elizabeth borne et à son gouvernement ce
soir moi je m'en fiche moi c'est très
fort vous savez bien qu'elle est née ici
on la vote depuis 4 ans tous les ans ici
ma boussole c'est pas Madame board ma
boussole moi c'est les Français je veux
que on sache ce soir qu'en 2030 quand
cette réforme va s'appliquer la France
sera le seul pays d'Europe ou en partira
à 64 ans ou on aura sans doute le
meilleur de tous les pays d'Europe le
meilleur régime de retraite notamment et
de prise en compte des carrières longues
c'est ça la vérité et qu'est-ce que vous
dites à vos électeurs qui peut-être se
disent que vous êtes la béquille de la
macronie ce soir je me fiche pour moi
l'intérêt général c'est ce qui surplombe
tout je n'ai pas tendu madame borne ou
Emmanuel Macron pour voter ce type de
mesure puisque ça fait 4 ans qu'on les
vote simplement expliquez-moi et la
gauche nous l'a pas expliqué comment
faire pour combler un déficit de plus de
150 milliards d'euros qui fera exploser
le système de retraite à très court
terme 150 milliards d'euros dans les 10
ans expliquez-moi comment est-ce qu'on
compense la démographie c'est à dire on
a toujours plus de retraités et il faut
payer les pensions et toujours moins de
cotisants alors comment on fait alors
encore une dernière question c'est sur
la suite du texte maintenant et bien il
va y avoir
une course jusqu'au au dimanche soir à
minuit pour finir l'examen des 20
articles et quid de la suite j'ai envie
de vous poser comme question et
qu'est-ce qui va se passer ensuite il va
y avoir comme ça
une recherche de compromis avec les
députés également écoutez après vous les
dire après le dimanche et je comprends
bien le 15 c'est-à-dire mercredi
prochain et il y aura une commission
c'est député sénateurs
un compromis je ne doute pas qu'on
trouve un compromis mais attendez là
vous anticipez un petit peu on n'est pas
encore à la CMP on est à la l'étape la
deuxième étape il y a eu le fiasco il y
a eu le fiasco de l'Assemblée nationale
et aujourd'hui le Sénat relève l'image
du Parlement sauf si la gauche s'entête
à faire de l'instruction parce que ça ça
va abîmer et j'en appelle mes collègues
de gauche que je connais bien et qui en
général sont respectueux du débat
parlementaire et démocratique n'abîmont
pas ce qui nous reste comme institution
parlementaire en France parce que sinon
c'est la porte ouverte à l'anti
parlementarisme et je pense que la
démocratie elle aussi sera abîmée j'ai
une toute dernière question si vous me
le permettez qu'est-ce que vous dites à
l'Inter syndical ils ont mobilisé des
centaines peut-être des millions de
personnes dans les rues 6 fois d'affilée
et ce sera peut-être qu'ils regardent
Public Sénat il voit le vote de cette
mesure dont ils ne veulent pas c'est à
dire l'intersyndicale la totalité des
des syndicats en France qu'est-ce que
vous leur répondez mais le droit de
grève c'est un droit qui est constituait
le même en reconnu ce que je voudrais
leur dire c'est que ils ont le droit de
manifester bien sûr mais surtout bravo
parce qu'ils ont manifesté dans l'ordre
et quand je vois les débats à
l'Assemblée nationale le désordre était
à l'Assemblée nationale l'ordre était
dans la rue
et bien merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]